Burp Suite Enterprise Edition offers a number of site-related settings that enable you to
fine-tune Burp Scanners' behaviour and provide additional information such as login credentials.
You can access these settings from the Scan Settings panel, either during the process of
creating a site as we are now, or while editing an existing site. The following tabs are available.
First, we have the Scan Configuration tab, which enables you to specify one or more configurations
to use when scanning the site. We have two options using a preset scan mode or a custom configuration.
If you'd like to learn more about scan configuration options, please see our documentation
defining scan configurations for a site. Next, we have Application Logins. This enables you to provide
login credentials for the site, and we have two options, the first of which is adding usernames
and passwords or uploading a recorded login sequence. If you'd like to learn more about
application logins for sites, please see our documentation configuring site login details.
Next, we have Extensions. This enables you to select any extensions that Burp Suite Enterprise
Edition should use when scanning the site. To learn more about this, please see our documentation
scanning with extensions. Next, we have Scanning Pool, which enables you to select a scanning pool for
the site to belong to. If you'd like to learn more about scanning pools, please see our documentation
managing scanning pools. And finally, we have Scan Notifications. This enables you to configure
automated notifications on Scan Progress. To learn how to set this up, please see our documentation
setting up Scan Notifications. Please note you must select a scan configuration in order to be able to
save the site. All of the settings in the Scan Settings section are optional. Thank you.